es conocido por su innovación en los
automóviles y la industria espacial y
ahora está planeado avanzar al siguiente
capítulo la robótica y lo más que él
siguió de tesla reveló los planes para
construir el tesla bot un prototipo de
robot humanoide el robot utilizará el
sistema de inteligencia artificial de
tesla y está diseñado para enfrentar
tareas peligrosas o aburridas que a la
gente no le gusta hacer y básicamente si
piensan en lo que estamos haciendo con
los autos tesla es probablemente la
compañía robótica más grande del mundo
porque los autos son como semi robots
sobre ruedas reos para que los humanos
puedan dominarlo el robot se moverá a
una velocidad de 8 kilómetros por hora
tendrá una altura de 17 metros y contará
con 8 cámaras y un computador de piloto
automático la seguridad es el problema
más grande para la compañía esta semana
las autoridades de estados unidos
abrieron una investigación en contra del
sistema de conducción asistida tras una
serie de accidentes
más que no comentó sobre el escrutinio y
afirmó que el prototipo estará listo
para 2022